dr. Alan Mendoza's the executive
director of the Henry Jackson Society
and he joins us tonight dr. Mendoza
thanks for coming on may pleasure to be
with you so do you think we're
overstating it when we described North
Korea as as basically a prison no of
course not it is basically a prison this
is the the world's most repressive
regime it is indeed a prison camp you
can't leave died in what your last guest
was were sort of smoking before she came
on but I have to say is most
extraordinary set of sort of points
disparate points put together in a in a
sort of a policy statement look this is
a state which exists and runs on terror
runs on terror
runs on torture it runs on imprisonment
and it runs on ensuring that the people
who live there are at the beckon whim of
the of the regime it is it is indeed a
prison camp you're absolutely correct
so why the impulse I mean you've you've
watched the reaction of the
international left to a lot of these
different regimes over the years why the
impulse to defend to side with to make
excuses for regimes that are
indefensible simply because they hate
the West there is an extraordinary
romance that the left actually believes
in when it comes to these regimes it
starts with the idea that actually we
can convert these people somehow and it
goes along the lines acts we have
something in common with them I think
you're right to highlight the fact that
the u.s. is frequently seen as a sort of
chief enemy of these regimes is actually
something that actually appeals to the
left as well yes and take those things
together you look at those two things
together and you realize that you get a
kind of complete opposite to what would
happen if it was a right-wing regime if
that was a case the Left would be first
out onto the street is saying we must
announce them must ignore them but when
it comes to someone who is purportedly
anti-american in that kind of way they
have a very different view it's sort of
strange though if you if you live in the
West in the UK or in the United States
and enjoy the fruits of the society why
devote your life to destroying it I mean
there's only the West does that right
well absolutely and here you come to the
crux the matter which is why is it the
citizens of our countries who enjoy free
societies
who enjoyed the ability to argue who
enjoyed the ability to discuss will go
out onto a limb to defend dictators
repressive regimes who prevent their
citizens from doing that is an
extraordinary extraordinary turn of
events when that happens what you should
be seeing what true liberals should be
doing is arguing for the inhabitants
those countries who are subjected to
human rights abuses getting them the
same rights that they themselves enjoy
but you don't have that at all no it's a
good points why fathers should be nice
to their children otherwise they'll grow
up to be progressives they'll hate you
and they'll make a whole politics out of
it Alan thank you very much